let's tell the jury about hicksville may
2013.
can you tell the jury what transpired at
hicksville
uh it is a
it's a
like a fancy
um trailer park
like a little hotel in the middle of
nowhere um set up with these little
trailers and
uh we had made um
a plan to go there with friends and um
we were gonna do
you know like laffy as we said laffy
drugs like
mushrooms eat mushrooms sit by a
campfire
um
there's really not a whole lot else to
do out there i just started smashing
things
he picked up something on the table and
threw it right into the glass cabinet
he hit with his hand
a wall sconce
he cleared the table top on the little
fold down um
like kitchen
dining room area in this trailer i mean
it's a trailer so there's only so much
you can do
and he's screaming at me
screaming at me i went into the bathroom
as i come out
he's at he asked me where it is
and how long i've been hiding it now
i was like what are you talking about
and he says you know what i'm talking
about you know what i'm talking about be
honest with me
where are you hiding it and he kind of
like makes to look into the bathroom
um and i gestured to the bathroom
which is to my right i kind of like
gestured to him and i said
like what what am i where am i good at
what am i hiding and where am i going to
hide it
and and we're standing in this little
hallway area
outside of the bathroom and
he starts
you know
what it feels like patting me down or
saying he's patting me down i can't
recall but
he ripped my dress
the
strap top part of my dress
i had just dyed this thing
myself pink and i
it's just one of those things i
was like
you know that's my
just finished that dress
and um he's like grabbing my
my breasts he's touching my thighs
and he rips my underwear off
and then
he
proceeds to do a cavity search
he was telling me we're doing we're
gonna we're gonna conduct a cavity
search shall we
like
just shoved his fingers inside me
just stood there staring at the stupid
light
you know what you know i didn't know
what to do i just stood
just stood there
while he did that he twisted his fingers
around
i don't
i didn't see like stop or anything i
just